wir kriegen sowas wie eine Diktatur das
sind Einzelpersonen die mit ihren
eigenen Interessen der Punkt auf einmal
den Himmel über uns entweder unter sich
aufteilen oder zu den Zwecken und Zielen
benutzen die nur sie definieren und zwar
selbst da muss noch nicht mal irgendeine
Berater Geist dabei gewesen sein sondern
da kommt jemand auf den Gedanken hat die
hat die Milliarden zur Verfügung setzt
das um und macht und das ist doch
eigentlich ein Zustand da kann man doch
nur hoffen dass das irgendwie
einigermaßen gut geht deswegen fühle ich
mich eben auch immer wieder an Moonraker
erinnert weil da ist ja eben genau auch
diese Situation und das
Erpressungspotential gerade angesichts
der Abhängigkeiten der der technisierten
Länder auf dem Planeten aber eigentlich
aller Kontinent wenn man mal überlegt
wie wichtig die die Kommunikation
natürlich inzwischen längst ist ähm das
kann doch so nicht bleiben wir können
doch solche Leute wie Maske oder anderen
nicht überlassen was über unseren Köpfen
passiert
[Musik]